une semaine après l'énorme manifestation
sur la place tiananmen nouveaux
rassemblements de masse aujourd'hui les
étudiants réclament la démocratisation
du régime et cela à l'occasion du 70e
anniversaire du tout premier mouvement
étudiant et lan risacher sans trop de
mal les étudiants chinois ont brisé les
cordons de police pour envahir la place
tiananmen de pékin pour la sixième
manifestation en trois semaines ils
étaient 300 mille aujourd'hui affirmant
ceci est un nouveau 4 mai du nom du
premier rassemblement étudiant de
l'histoire de la chine
il y à 70 ans exactement les étudiants
d'aujourd'hui réclament la démocratie la
fin de la corruption et la
reconnaissance de leur association
indépendante
ils ont été longuement applaudis par les
passants et pour la première fois
quelques 300 journalistes de la presse
officielle se sont joints aux étudiants
pour protester contre la censure et
obtenir la liberté de la presse en fin
d'après-midi les cortèges se sont
dispersés sans incidents sans
intervention policière violente
demain à l'appel des leaders de leur
mouvement les étudiants doivent
reprendre leur cours après deux semaines
de grève
le secrétaire général du pc chinois zao
viande après dit tout à l'heure que la
fièvre allait retomber confirmant ainsi
indirectement que le régime avait choisi
de miser sur l'essoufflement du
mouvement plutôt que sur l'affrontement
direct avec les contestataires
aujourd'hui à paris pour la première
fois quelques dizaines d'étudiants
chinois manifesté leur soutien quelque
chose comme vous voyez celui là on a
écrit cinq mille ans de civilisation et
puissante que c'était trop tard je crois
que tout le monde comprend ce que ça
veut dire mais pour ses étudiants il a
été impossible d'atteindre l'ambassade
de chine